[Music]
so mentors
you mentioned changing your mind is
important and you said let's come back
if you like to mentors because you have
one in mind um do you still have that
threat if so would you like to
pick up on that
peter thiel
so peter came back as a ceo if you've
read any of the paypal books and know
the story you know
we as a team rally to get him back as
ceo it was difficult because the board
wasn't fully supportive and we had to
keep as a team we had to keep
interviewing other candidates and we get
feeling no but peter
we're a team and peter's peter's our man
and we want peter to be our leader and
our ceo and so
peter had incredible ability to change
his mind
peter would say we're turning left we're
turning left and then you know we
weren't sure we'd go analyze bring him
data we'd show him the results and he'd
say yep i've just looked at it returning
right and he would just turn like that
on a dime and he had no qualms about
this and i think most people get so
stuck in escalation of commitment where
i need to remain consistent with the
person you thought i was yesterday
otherwise i'm going to be viewed as
irrational there's a whole branch of
psychology that talks about this
right and to some extent people view
flip-floppers negatively especially in
politics and things like that but in
business it's incredibly valuable if
you're just rational and peter did that
to a t and made him an incredible ceo
do you think that's just peter out of
the box
different motherboard different
programming or is that something that he
cultivated and if you think there's a
component of it
that is cultivated
how do you think he did that or how
would you help someone to develop
that ability
so i don't know if because i obviously
didn't know him growing up i've you know
met him in the paypal context so
i mean peter's just so supremely smart
and rational that i my guess is it's
innate in him and he just he doesn't
suffer that kind of baggage if you will
yeah
and he thinks for himself i think a lot
of people that are so worried about what
others think of them
and peter just doesn't seem encumbered
by that not that he's indifferent to it
but i just don't think he spends his
whole life worrying about what others
think about him he just does what he
thinks is right
and and interesting yeah
so
i think it's innate i think in terms of
cultivating it
just calling it for what it is
you know in an organization creating a
culture where you're willing to stand up
to new information and change your mind
and then praising people for changing
their mind on things
you know look i i said no to this
decision i've reevaluated or i walked
into the partner meeting thinking we
shouldn't make this investment
and i've been swayed by your arguments
or recognizing that somebody else
changed their mind and praising them for
doing that i think you need to cultivate
that kind of culture
you